مكسب شديد لزيلين سكي برعايه الحلفاء
الاوروبيين هذه الطائرات ستصبح قريبا في
ايدي طيار الجيش الاوكراني هولندا
والدنمارك اعلنتا انهما ستسلمان طائرات اف
16 الى اوكرانيا
للاحتفاء بهذا الحدث سافر رئيس الاوكراني
برفقه زوجته الى كلا البلدين لفحص
الطائرتين في قاعده جويه هولنديه ثم بعد
ساعات قليله في قاعده دنماركيه
بالتبرع بالطائرات الغربيه المقاتله اذا
صارت الامور كما يجب في بدايه العام
الجديد ستغادر المجموعه الاولى من
الطائرات الدنماركيه الى اوكرانيا
جيلينسكي القى خطابا امام البرلمان
الدنماركي عبر من خلاله عن امتنانه للدعم
الذي تقدمه الدول الغربيه لبلاده محذرا من
امكانيه توسع الخطر الروسي
[تصفيق]
نحن هنا لنشكركم جميعا على مساعدتنا في
كفاحنا الصعب من اجل الحريه
لمساعدتنا في هذه الحرب التي جلبتها روسيا
الى ارضنا
الان يقصف الجيش الروسي المدن والقرى
الاوكرانيه
لكنهم يقولون علانيه ان اوكرانيا ليست
كافيه
لاحقا سوف ينقلون هذه المعاناه الى اوروبا
والى كامل انحاء العالم
تحدث هذه الطائرات فرقا على الارض ولكن
على المدى الطويل من المرجح ان تساعدك في
تنفيذ هجومها المضاد ضد موسكو